i'm on clubhouse now which is a new app
that uh i have invites to and none of
you are getting invites
uh clubhouse is an invite-only app it's
drop-in audio chat
it's a social network that's based on
your voice where people around the world
come to network talk to each other
have open conversations about the issues
of the day
and i was sponsored by michael gruen who
is a
uh bitcoin guy also he owns the uh
sway house which is a tick tock house in
los
angeles and he's a very funny guy who uh
is very successful entrepreneur and he
brought me on
and everybody on there not everybody but
a lot of people on there
are entrepreneurs venture capitalists
investors people that uh have come up
with very successful apps
really really successful people in the
tech space
and a lot of the rooms are very fun we
goof around they bring me on i'm like
you know they invite me as a speaker i'm
a comedian i throw in a funny line
every few minutes but reality i listen i
listen
and some of the conversations are very
interesting and informative and some of
them are terrifying
because you're meeting your captors
truly you're
you're getting into a they're running
the world
they're going to run the world they're
going to win when they talk they have
this very
cold blooded like you know some of them
say well you know
we have to put guard rails up online
don't we
and you're like god they're gonna win
it's terrifying but they're gonna win
but it really is for a guy like me i'm
listening to my cat
it would be like if there was an app in
the 1800s where
slaves could ask questions to their
masters
so you're shackled in a barn and you get
to go on an app and go
what do we think tomorrow is it field
tomorrow and they go
well production has been very low and we
do blame the weather but a lot of that
is because we feel that the manpower is
lacking so we are going to get in the
field tomorrow
and then we're going to try to
streamline that we're going to really
try to cover all of our bases i think
what is really important is that we
build an infrastructure
and then you're sitting there as a slave
and you go yeah that sounds good and one
day i'll be a master
i'm gonna own a plantation one day and
i'll shackle people up in a barn
and tell them what they can and can't
say and how they can say it it is a
little terrifying on there and it's fun
and it's funny but when you hear these
people talk
um they love the penta i mean they
they're they're gushing
one guy goes there's gonna be a pandemic
now every five years it's just the way
the world is now
it's just the way the world is
everyone's gonna have to wear masks
forever
we were sharing way too many germs
before everybody
stay in your house stay online and use
our app
use our app the world is now different
and
all the things that can make the world
livable
coincidentally are all the things we've
invested in
isn't that nice don't go outside there's
new strains every day is another strain
the andromeda strain
they're all coming from brazil from
africa yeah it's coming
they're all coming the strains won't end
and then these people on this app are
talking about the new world that
everyone will live in which will be
digital forever
it is the dystopian nightmare that you
feared they are preparing it for you
as you sleep truly they are and not to
sound too crazy about it
but when you hear these people talk and
they're they're not emotional
it's very cold it's calculated they're
just like this is how it is now
we're living in the world of pandemics
we're gonna get one all the time
they're gonna be here and in order to
live with this new world we're gonna
have to distance
we're gonna have to use this our
infrastructure that we've built
this is what you have to use you have to
be online all the time using our apps
to make a living to do anything and by
the way
if you get a little wacky we're gonna
delete you delete and where are you
gonna go
there's nowhere for you to go there's
nowhere for you to go because you're
gonna get another strain
don't walk into an office the strains
coming
as that's the strain from pakistan
it's the pakistani strain so you have no
other option
you know create your own twitter people
went on parlor they said ab [ __ ] that
well you can make money in the market if
you want buy stocks
ah [ __ ] that we'll turn that off
and pretty soon and it's already
happening it's like
you know we'll just start deleting you
your ability to to earn a living
if we so choose this is enforced
compliance
and the guys that are on the other side
of that guy's like eric weinstein who's
on clubhouse all the time he's a really
brilliant guy he talks
you know 19 20 hours a day on clubhouse
every day
and it's still not enough you know it's
like tulsi gabbard was in a room with
him and somebody would ask her a
question and he'd
be like tulsi what's it like running a
presidential campaign weinstein jumps in
he's like
here's what tulsi learned you're like
wait what but
he's he is an ally right eric weinstein
actually doesn't want
this and you hope that he wins but i
don't know if he will
because the other side seems to be very
uh competent and they seem to be
and this is just listening on this app
which i spent three or four hours on a
night
because it's [ __ ] fascinating i do a
little joke every now and then everybody
goes oh tim's a comedian
isn't that funny uh but they i'm a roach
in there they look at me like a
i'm like a jester that they bring out
like hey make everyone laugh and then
we're gonna talk about uh you know the
type of shackles that we get that's
gonna go right around the arm
yeah we got a good one we're saving
money on metal so the chain the chain
we're switching from metal we're gonna
do an elastic chain it's like a polymer
so you feel like you can go somewhere
but it snaps you back
so and that's what they talk about and
then every now and then i come in and i
make a joke and i'm like you know
i'm like well what about my polymer
chain and they go
but it to to listen to them it's it's
it's a little
uh disturbing it's a little disturbing
how
intuit they are in terms of like
you know this pandemic there's no end in
sight and never will be
there's never going be that and again
it's not this like
vast conspiracy this is how these
[ __ ] make their money
this is how they're gonna make their
money and they're gonna pretend that
they're the greatest people that have
ever lived
and they've ushered humanity into this
new era of not being able to leave your
home or speak
and it's for your own good they're
crying on cnbc because they're
worried about you because they care
about you you're not going to be able to
speak or buy stocks or leave your house
because they care don't ever forget that
this
is wrapped up in altruism in a way that
like nothing ever
finance guys are like cuddly care bears
compared to the tech people finance guys
are like yeah we're here to rob you
they're they're clumsy they're idiots
this fat [ __ ] on cnbc's crying
he's clearly a goon you can identify him
and go goon
they wear pinstripe suits i mean they
might as well be the monopoly guy you
could see them coming a mile away
these finance guys or even though
they're in their jeans now these hedge
fund douchebags with their [ __ ]
aviators
you you still can see them and know but
the tech people
really are utopians they are creating a
new world and they just might let you
live in it
they just might let you live in that
world
for a little bit until you get visibly
upset
you know and that's when they're gonna
have to get you out of there
that's where they're gonna have to open
the trap door and you're
done and you hear that when somebody
said to me and this was a big
big person who said we need to put guard
rails up online
i get a little heart flutter a little
palpitation i'm like what do you mean by
that
and then later on a guy comes in and
goes listen we're gonna have another
pandemic every five years
so we're never gonna be able to go back
to living the way we used to live we
shared way too many germs
work is gonna be exclusively from home
you're gonna have to use these uh
applications
this is the way we're gonna do things
now this is the wave of the future
friends are gone unless they're digital
i mean it's really wild
uh to to hit you know the vaccines are
coming
uh and some of them we need without a
doubt
but they're coming there'll be 12 of
them you won't know which one to get
everyone there'll be different vaccines
different vaccine for every season it'll
be like fashion week
with needles what's the spring line look
like
you know are you getting a summer
vaccine what's to some you know
gucci will start making them soon
they'll have vaccines from everybody
and and that's it and public health
policy
and and tech policy is all going to be
fused together
and it's all going to be to help you
it's going to be it's all going to be
for you
that's all and there's going to be a
cartel of companies that you have to do
business with to exist on this planet
and if you choose not to and i remember
when like you know i would talk to
people and this was
years ago and we've even talked to them
on the show where they'd go no what's
coming is fully autonomous
cities where everything is delivered to
you via drone you you don't really need
to leave if you leave there's like a
park you can go to
uh that'll be monitored there'll be
cameras everywhere you're gonna be
listened to
uh the alexa will just be the beginning
every single uh appliance in your house
will be a smart appliance to listen to
everything you say they'll
they'll use that information to market
things to you which will be delivered by
drone
and then if you go on let you know
there'll be social credit scores similar
to china
uh are you a team player or are you
disgruntled are you anti-social
and what the line of that is just
they're gonna keep moving it they
keep moving the line of is of what's
considered anti-social
what's considered a problem and it's
just go it'll stifle
all art which is already dead let's be
very honest there's
there's very few things out there that
you go god is that good
god was that good it's gonna be what you
see now
tick tock people dancing you know
buy the merch i'm gonna dance in a
stairwell
in a mansion and that's it that's what
you're gonna get you'll get
movies that are a little more than spon
con you're gonna just get spon con
you know so yeah it'll be vaccine spon
con
you'll just watch your favorite avenger
get vaccinated
even the hulk needs a shot don't worry
it's coming
folks being on this app for three
[ __ ] days
it's coming tomorrow it's not coming in
six months or a year
it's here you just don't know it yet i'm
telling you right now
everything you see now is so insane
pregnant people
not pregnant women pregnant people
tweet a man can't get pregnant you'll
lose your account you will
lose your account you're a turf
you're a biological essentialist i'm
telling you right now
this disease has gotten to the brain
it's spread it's like a doctor sitting
down and going
the disease has spread there's not going
to be any let up
really and i was like so
taken back by how cold and calculated
um a lot of these people are in these
abs and how they really
truly believe that they're doing the
right thing for you
they truly believe that they actually
believe it
it's not like a bunch of wall street
guys in the room going hey we're getting
over
it's true believers it's a cult and they
believe that the world should look a
certain
way and if you fit into that you fit
into that and if you do not fit into
that you are going away
you're gonna go away and
you know i mean these articles come out
we've talked about it with whitney webb
but you know where they go listen
you're going to own nothing you're going
to be happy you're not going to own a
car
you won't own a house good luck you
might not own stock you're not going to
own a business
you won't own your own body soon because
they'll tell you what has to go into
that what's allowed what's not allowed
um and this is the future and i've never
been more convinced of it than spending
time on that
and the app is fun it's fun
hearing how it's gonna happen isn't that
sick
it's actually fun hearing how they're
gonna get ya
it's amusing it's better than tv
stop watching ozark listen to your
captors
they're telling you they are telling you
you don't
need the next season but to marty and
wendy figure out
who cares these people are telling you
how they're going to shackle you to a
floorboard
listen to them i'm telling you don't
make the mistake don't make the mistake
of ignoring them when they talk
don't ignore what is going to be the
future of your life
and your children's life i wish it
wasn't fun
because it is fun going huh that's a
good idea
how are you going to remove
all my freedom little by little and i'll
thank you for it
i'll thank thank you thank you for
this that's what they want elizabeth
warren wants you to thank her for
telling you you can't make any money she
wants you to come and
say thank you for protecting me from
prosperity
thank you for protecting me from earning
a dollar
thank god i was about to earn forty
thousand dollars and maybe pay down some
student debt and help my mother out
thank christ you got in the way of that
hoof
i mean that's truly where we're at now
as a country
but that clubhouse that man it's a lot
of fun except our friend keeps ruining
it
we have this friend alex who keeps
rooting and he jumps in every room
you got to get invited to these rooms
and i want new friends i want to be
friends with the captors
i want to be friends with them these
some of these people are so young
they're in their early 20s
they started a hedge fund at like four
years old very wealthy
yeah the instagram picture is like them
tongue-kissing joe biden these people
are connected
i want those they're i want to be
friends with them
i want to be friends with the captors
so every now and then they could they
could let me out of the cage
and i'll do a dance and then they bring
me right back in and i go
can i can i stay on the property tonight
they go not tonight
back in the cage but we really enjoyed
the show and i go okay
thank you because you'll say thank you
thank you and then go please vaccinate
tim on the way back so he forgets
everything that happened
but i'm trying to make friends and then
alex
keeps ruining it by jumping in and not
shutting his goddamn mouth
shut your mouth alex i'm known a little
bit on this thing so i'm a comedian so
like sometimes they let me in the rooms
and they wouldn't know who i am some of
them know who i am because i've done
rogue and a bunch they're all like we
want rogan
to be on clubhouse i spoke to him he's
like i'm busy mom [ __ ] that mom
yeah you're never gonna get he's never
gonna be on clubhouse dummy
but like we're talking to tulsi on there
and we're talking eric weinstein it's a
lot of fun
it's the future
and it's fun but some of those rooms in
there you're like
whoo it's gonna get
interesting going forward it will